el gobierno aprobó hoy en el consejo de
ministros el texto del proyecto
de ley sobre la reforma pensional esta
reforma pensional que lleva la edad de
jubilación de 62 a 64 años a partir de
dos mil treinta este texto no tuvo
modificación alguna a pesar de las
manifestaciones multitudinarias de la
semana pasada en los que pues los
franceses entre uno a dos millones de
trabajadores a franceses protestaron en
contra de esta voluntad del gobierno de
Emanuel macron después de la
presentación de este texto Olivia el
ministro de trabajo también dio una
rueda de prensa en la que volvió a
defender esta reforma explicándo lo
importante que es para volver a llegar
al equilibrio de las finanzas públicas
del país de todo este sistema y dijo que
se tendrá muy en cuenta la penosidad del
trabajo las personas que comenzaron a
trabajar A muy temprana edad y también
pues se vigilará también el trabajo de
los adultos mayores para eso ha de un
indicativo en las empresas de más de 300
empleados en todo caso este texto de ley
comenzará a ser estudiado a partir de El
próximo seis de febrero examinado por
parte de la asamblea nacional luego será
el turno de El senado y se espera ya un
voto ya definitivo para finales del mes
de marzo